(sad music)
- When I'm depressed,
trying to do anything
feels like trying to start
a car when there is no gas
in the car.
You can really want to go somewhere,
you can really wanna do the thing,
but you literally don't have the means.
It can feel as heavy as a
boulder, or as light to carry
around as my fingernail, but
it's as much a part of me
as that fingernail is.
- Depression to me feels
like a giant weight,
kind of like one of those big dumb bells.
It starts right in your
gut, and you just feel it
slowly intensifying.
So it starts out small, and
then all of the sudden it gets
a little bit bigger, a little bit bigger,
it goes down to your stomach,
it goes up to your heart,
it kind of spreads
throughout your entire body.
And it just gets slowly
heavier and heavier
and just a little bit harder
to deal with and a little
bit harder to carry.
And then it gets really overwhelming.
- Having anxiety feels like
a million bubbles filled with
things that could go wrong
that are just pushing on me.
And each bubble is filled with something
that could go wrong.
And all of the things that could go wrong,
are irrational to a normal
person, but to someone
with anxiety, the thing
that could go wrong feels
like the worst thing in the world.
- It kind of feels like
rolling in a ball down a hill.
You do start to feel a
little bit like a roly poly,
and you just kind of
collapse in on yourself.
Like one little kind of
thing that you get fixated on
and then it just kind of starts
to spin and spin and spin
around you until you kind of
feel like you can't control
all the things that are
worrying you anymore.
- I have obsessive compulsive disorder,
to me that's always felt
like having a separate
cloud of a mind outside of my own mind.
Sort of a buzzing gray
hive of thoughts that come
in and out of my own
brain, and can be busy
or less busy depending on
how I'm feeling on the day.
- OCD is like a faucet
dripping over and over
and over again, and you keep
having all these irrational
thoughts, and you know they're irrational,
but you just keep having them.
And they are so important
to you in that moment,
and it's all led by fear.
- ADD feels kind of like being
this high functioning robot,
but if you went into the mind
of the robot and actually
learned what the robot is
thinking, it's just like
a bunch of Katy Perry songs
and old childhood memories.
- It has this huge importance to you.
- This is the thing that
actually impacts many, many,
many people, but people
don't actually do anything
about it because we are
trained to think that it's
not a problem, or it's
something that we can control
when sometimes it actually isn't.
- There is a lot of beauty
that can come out of it.
There are strengths to it for
sure, and I think a lot of
creative people especially,
have figured out ways to
connect ideas and use it
in a creative sort of way.